okay I want to show you the new
emulation feature in chrome dev tools
and it's great for understanding how
your contents going to look across
different devices so I'm gonna start
here on the Wikipedia site and you can
see when I resize the site down that it
doesn't scale well I don't get any sense
of how this site would play out if I
were viewing it on a phone for example
so if I open up dev tools and bring up
the console using the Escape key on the
keyboard and you can also use this icon
up here you'll see that there's a new
tab called emulation now there are lots
of really interesting things inside of
here like screen resolution device pixel
ratio user agent strings another fun
stuff like geolocation now emulation is
gonna let me set all of these things
individually and have total control over
how Chrome's going to present itself to
any given site but to make life a little
bit easier we've also included a bunch
of device presets so I'm gonna go ahead
and choose the Nexus 4 here that's
that's a bunch of these features on
which you can see now have this blue
check next to them because the Wikipedia
site actually serves different content
to mobile devices I'm gonna need to
refresh the page and now you'll see that
we're so the mobile site now we've done
a bunch of work to make sure that the
emulation behaves as close to reality as
possible and one of the things you're
going to notice is that my cursor is
turned into this dot and that's because
we're emulating touch including proper
touch events so if I hold shift and
click drag you'll see that I'm also able
to mimic pinch to zoom this whole
experience is far better than simply
spoofing the user agent string you can
really start to get a sense of how your
projects going to react for any given
device I also want to show you this demo
to give you a bit more detail on device
pixel ratio you'll see that my desktop
has a device pixel ratio of 1 and if we
take a peek at the source file you'll
see that we're using image set to choose
the most appropriate image right now
that's the One X image I turn on
emulation inside the dev tools and set
the device pixel ratio to two you'll see
that we're now serving the 2x image this
is super useful when you're looking to
test serving the right assets based on
device pixel ratio whether you have
access to a high DPI device or not so
that's just the taste of emulating
mobile devices please take a look around
use it in your workflow and head to dev
tools chrome comm to learn more